battles on the high seas ominous hints
at Future foes and a slightly more
sympathetic shark man here's what the
ending of Netflix's one piece means
season one of one piece on Netflix
adapts the manga and anime's opening
East blue Saga the story follows Monkey
D Luffy a good-natured young pirate
whose body stretches like rubber due to
eating a devil fruit seeking out the one
piece The Treasure of Legendary Pirate
gold D Roger Luffy assembles a crew over
the course of the Season each member
with their own unique abilities and
goals I'm Monkey D Luffy and I will be
the king of the Pirates
I think you should join my crew The
Swordsman Zorro and The Navigator Nami
are the first to join him Usopp a teller
of Tall Tales who's mastered using a
slingshot joins them in syrup village
where the crew also gets a new ship the
going Mary Sanji a womanizing waiter
with martial arts skills volunteers to
become these Straw Hat Pirates chef but
just when it seems like Luffy's pirate
dreams are coming true Nami betrays the
group she does it for a good reason
though when Nami was a child arlong
murdered her adoptive mother and
conquered her hometown of Cocoa Village
Nami has since been robbing pirates for
the purpose of getting enough money to
buy the village back from arlong a plan
that is doomed to failure thankfully the
straw hats arrived to save the day and
Luffy agrees to help her defeat arlong
meanwhile Kobe and helmeppo Marines who
crossed paths with Luffy in the first
episode are pursuing the straw hats
while working under vice admiral GARP
who turns out to be Luffy's grandfather
in the season finale worst in the East
the straw hat Pirates do battle with the
arlong Pirates on behalf of the people
of Cocoa Village Luffy faces off against
arlong himself fighting inside arlong
Park's Central Building the fish man is
invulnerable to the rubber boy's attacks
but Luffy realizes that he doesn't need
to hurt arlong directly he just needs to
destroy the building so it crashes down
on top of him the plan works with our
long defeated and Luffy the Victor just
as the straw hats are celebrating their
Victory with the Villagers the Marines
come in to arrest them Kobe and Hal mepo
refuse garp's orders but GARP goes ahead
to challenge his grandson to a fight
this is ultimately meant as a test of
Luffy's resolve and GARP lets him go
when it's clear nothing can change his
mind GARP later reveals he respects how
Kobe and helmeppo stuck to their
personal codes of justice and offers to
train them one Marine Captain nazumi is
upset that GARP doesn't actually want to
arrest the straw hat and puts Luffy on a
wanted poster with a high Bounty Kobe
shows Luffy the poster no knowing he'll
be overjoyed at achieving such infamy as
a pirate Luffy brings several orange
trees from Cocoa Village aboard the
going Mary to remind Nami of home while
Nami and the other straw hats gift Luffy
a Mainsail with the group's new Insignia
and with that the straw hats sail off
towards the grand line
altogether season one of Netflix's one
piece compresses about 11 volumes of the
manga or 45 half hour episodes of the
anime into eight hour long episodes and
that's not even counting the GARP
subplot which mostly reflects content
from way later in the source material
that results in a pretty packed series
and this is taken to its greatest
extreme in the series finale this one
live-action episode covers around 15
chapters of the manga or eight episodes
of the anime plus an original GARP vs
Luffy fight that the show is able to fit
this much content into a single episode
is in large part due to a very different
approach to handling the fights while
making sure to accurately adapt the
character's fighting techniques what was
originally a series of individual
standoffs between different straw hats
and fishmen gets changed into a
fast-paced cross-cutting battle that's
over in 20 minutes it's certainly a
different feel for action than other
versions of One Piece gaining speed but
losing some of the drama while some fans
might not be happy at the rapid
fireplace case at the very least one
piece can't face the hardly anything
happens in an individual episode
criticism that often applies to
binge-ready streaming shows
arlong is the type of villain where half
of the time when he speaks you think
he's basically in the right if a little
misguided and the other half of the time
you think he's the most loathsome person
ever in the world of One Piece fishmen
have been enslaved and oppressed by
humans and arlong seeks to liberate them
by enslaving and oppressing humans in
turn his motivation is rooted in an
understandable rage at Injustice but his
actions in response are so evil that he
loses sympathy I'm just playing by human
rules
with these mems I will create a world
with a Fish Supreme in the Manga and
Anime versions of the arlong park Arc
arlong is even less sympathetic the
history of bigotry against the fish men
isn't revealed in detail until much
later in the series so initially Arlan
comes across as purely an anti-human
bigot revealing his backstory earlier
creates a very different impression of
the character and makes him a more
compelling villain to Center the first
season around
the most obvious change from the Manga
and Anime so far in the live-action one
piece is that GARP is introduced way
earlier Luffy's Marine grandfather is
initially revealed via a run of cover
stories about Kobe and helmeppo which
was adapted into episode 68 and 69 of
the anime GARP doesn't reunite with
Luffy or play a role in the main
storyline until the end of the water 7
Saga and this reunion happens under very
different circumstances than in the live
action show the decision to bring garpin
earlier seems to be made with an
intention of building more drama from
the straw hats interactions with the
Marines the conflict is certainly more
personal having family on opposite sides
of the law GARP also becomes The
Season's final boss of sorts fighting
Luffy in a battle that can serve as a
climax for the whole season in contrast
to the rest of the show's relatively
self-contained two episode arcs
in contrast to the Manga and Anime where
characters can disappear for long
stretches before making their big
reappearances Netflix's one piece seems
to want to have as many of its
supporting characters appear as often as
possible our long is introduced as early
as episode 3 in an attempt to build him
up as a villain without the luxury of
being able to give him a 15 episode Arc
like the anime could Kobe and talmepo
are presences throughout the season
partially as a means to emphasize the
theme of there being good people on both
sides of the law be a good Marine
buggy the clown gets an expanded role in
the live-action adaptation that greatly
differs from his original role in the
Manga and Anime here buggy teams up with
arlong and uses his chop chop fruit
abilities to track down the straw hats
the straw hats then use buggy in the
same fashion to track down Nami after
she leaves in the season finale buggy
abandons the battle with the Fishman
after reattaching all his body parts
together he swears to kill Luffy after
seeing his Bounty poster before fellow
villain alvida says she wants to do it
herself
in the pre-credits scene a man shown
from behind sits at a desk holding two
cigars with one of these cigars he burns
Luffy's wanted poster no name is listed
in the credits since the character is
only shown from behind it's likely the
role has yet to be officially cast but
any one-piece fan can tell you this
character is smoker smoker is a marine
who serves as both a Relentless enemy
and occasionally an unlikely Ally to
Luffy he is first introduced in the log
Town Arc though it remains unclear
exactly what the Netflix adaptation
plans to do with that Arc given it is
technically part of the East blue Saga
already adapted in season one even if
the timing of his introduction is
changed however he's sure to play a
major role in future Seasons should the
show get renewed due to the writer's
guilt of America and Screen Actors Guild
strikes in summer 2023 season 1 of the
live-action one piece has not had a
traditional press cycle in terms of cast
and writing crew discussing every detail
of the show in interviews however
Netflix sent out a packet of press notes
featuring pre-strike interviews where
some creatives talked vaguely about the
ending original manga author aichiro Oda
alluded to The Season's end point by
saying the story will span 8 episodes
and take us up through you nowhere based
on what parts of the manga were
announced to be adapted fans would know
that you know where refers to the Grand
line Nami actress Emily Rudd didn't talk
about the season finale but when asked
about the scene that made her a
one-piece fan she did discuss the scene
when her character finally asks Luffy
for help she wants to do everything
herself and that moment is the first
time in years maybe ever that she has
ever asked anyone for help she continued
that's when you realize they're a crew
that their family and that speaks to the
heart of the show it's all about love
and family supporting each other and
following your dreams in her darkest
moment you have someone there saying I
got you Nami isn't some tool to be used
she's a person with wants and dreams of
her own whether Netflix's one piece will
be renewed for a second season remains
on certain infamously the last
live-action anime adaptation from
Netflix and tomorrow's Studios Cowboy
Bebop was canceled after just one season
despite debuting with supposedly High
viewership numbers whereas Cowboy Bebop
Creator shanichara Watanabe was
completely hands-off and ultimately
disappointed with the adaptation the
live-action one piece has had the full
support of and significant involvement
from aichiro Oda however some fans still
feel that the show has significant
artistic and pacing problems there's no
guarantee the live-action version will
be a hit should there be a second season
there's plenty of new characters to see
including the members of the villainous
Baroque Works Syndicate including future
Straw Hat Nico Robin and the reindeer Dr
Chopper handling Chopper in live action
might be the biggest challenge the
adaptation faces yet here's hoping we
get to see them give it a shot